[Music]
foreign
my name is Hussein fancy my name is
Allison my name is Pina mogese I'm
Jessica Fitzgerald I'm fadila yahir I am
CJ argue I'm Hong shalu my name is Jane
Lynch
[Music]
I'm a scholar of medieval Europe and the
Islamic world I work on herpes viruses
which are incredibly common human
pathogens I'm a historian of Southeast
Asia my lab studies fundamental
mechanisms of human reproduction my
research is in robotics interactive
robot learning ultimately we want to
make Electronics the voices that can be
used for energy applications in the
future I specialize in Islamic law and
colonialism and I work with at least
five languages Arabic French Malay
English and Dutch I'm a sociocultural
anthropologist and what I'm particularly
interested in is how ethical and moral
questions emerge in the context of
economic life I take people to the
Middle Ages because it is a foreign
country for them it is a place that they
will be detached from everything they
understand of the world and return them
to the present has changed people we
hope to make fundamental discoveries
concerning the basis of human
infertility the virus that I work on is
called caposi sarcomas
virus which is interesting because it
can cause cancer and immune compromised
individuals as a historian of Southeast
Asia and as someone who is actually from
there I think that I offer a unique
perspective on the region
I'm an energy Science Institute and the
idea of having that Institute is to
gather faculties from different
departments who are working on energy
applications so people can work together
and collaborate with each other do
corporations have a social
responsibility should we try to create
social change through the things that we
buy at stores these are the kinds of
questions that I Center my courses
around but also that emerge within the
context of the research that I do
experience of math as a social activity
appreciating that it's something that is
best done through collaboration and
experimentation working with other
people and being willing to mess up
together and then get on the right track
together will ultimately lead to a much
deeper appreciation for them
what I hope to achieve from here is
things that would not have been possible
in other places that is scholarship
interactions and collaborations across
different disciplines we are working on
a very interdisciplinary research that
will combine Material Science chemistry
and electrical engineering I hope to
build a strong happy lab full of
scientists from all walks of life
I'm excited to teach I'm excited to
expose some of the best students in the
country to the material that I find
fascinating and interesting
there's still a lot of unsolved problems
out there and so what I really hope to
do
these natural Curiosities and interests
that students have about Ai and Robotics
and turn that into questions that they
want to solve My Hope here is not only
to perform Cutting Edge research but
also to teach students from diverse
backgrounds to be a role model to send
the message that this is really
achievable for everyone I want them to
learn the way to solve a problem and how
they think is very important the young
the knowledge in the textbook to
encourage them to be attentive to very
ordinary things to slow down and become
observers of the world around them and
things that seem mundane or irrelevant
but that end up being the small details
that open up very large worlds what
we're doing in the hour and a half that
we're together we're cultivating a sense
of how to understand and question the
world in front of us and also How to
shed an alarming sense of certainty that
so many people have that they know what
the world is I think that becomes part
of a lifelong journey of
self-understanding
research problems are problems that by
definition have not been solved by
anyone before and so there's going to be
a lot of obstacles so the biggest
question isn't necessarily how much do
you know about this topic but rather how
long are you willing to stick with this
and continue to learn even after you
make mistakes and even after an approach
doesn't work until you come across the
right solution I think that kind of
stubbornness is ultimately what makes a
researcher successful being at Yale
offers us the scientific tools and
Facilities to perform our research at
the highest level
I was an undergraduate at Yale many
years ago so part of the appeal was to
return to a place that I love What
attracted me to Yale was the Yale
history Department which is a which is a
top history Department
What attracted me to Yale is just how
much computer science and engineering
are growing here everybody is so
invested in teaching as much as they are
in their own scholarship and learning
there's this very palpable sense that
learning here is like a connection to a
lot of history that has happened on this
campus there's a sense that there's more
at stake here than just the immediate
task at hand I'm very excited to be like
part of that kind of a community and
connect with a bigger sense of what
we're really doing here oh The Faculty
members and the chair and the dean
they're very helpful and supportive on
new faculty members and they really want
the junior faculty member to be
successful at Yale part of what I love
about being you know and part of what
drew me back here was that I was an
English major as an undergraduate I
never took a history class as a
undergraduate but I've returned as a
history professor and to me that says a
great deal about the kind of education I
got here the liberal arts themselves you
know and I'm excited to be a part of a
community where we teach people how to
read to think and the ways in which it
imbues their lives and really surprising
ways
[Music]
[Applause]